et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Laurent jacobelli bonjour bon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous de la Moselle
porte-parole du rassemblement national
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
Christelle Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche
bonjour Christelle bonjour Oriane
bonjour Laurent
évidemment par la crise des carburants à
l'orange jacobelli face au pénuries de
carburant au fil d'attente qui s'allonge
dans les stations services et les abats
de borne a donc annoncé hier la
réquisition des personnels vaisseaux
pour débloquer les dépôts c'est la bonne
réponse ah comme toujours ce
gouvernement attend qu'il soit trop tard
pour réagir avec des mesures toujours un
peu dures un peu brutales même si elles
sont nécessaires moi je me rappelle de
l'interview de Monsieur Véran
porte-parole de ce même gouvernement qui
nous disait il y a quelques jours
pénurie d'essence oh ben jamais il y a
absolument aucun risque ces gens ne
préparent rien ne voit jamais les
catastrophes arrivées et quand elles
arrivent quand elles arrivent ils
réagissent et il est trop tard vous
savez il va pas falloir laisser les
Français sans essence c'est dangereux
des ambulances roulent avec de l'essence
des camions de pompiers donc il va
falloir bien évidemment débloquer les
dépôts d'essence malheureusement
évidemment prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent bien sûr mais c'est trop tard
il aurait fallu réagir avant de négocier
avant ce gouvernement aurait pu voir des
signaux quand le patron de Total
s'augmente de 52%, quand cette même
entreprise fait des surprofis de 16
milliards d'euros en un an et bien là il
aurait dû prendre des résolutions il
aurait dû s'assurer de la redistribution
de cet argent notamment auprès des
Français nous vous savez on propose oui
d'accord on a vu aussi que cela généré
un certain nombre de stations fermées
auprès des salariés d'abord auprès des
Français nous on voulait créer une
surtaxe de 25% sur les surprofistes
c'est-à-dire les profits générés par la
crise en Ukraine ou par l'inflation mais
il fallait probablement aussi réfléchir
avec les salariés imaginez le symbole un
patron qui s'augmente de 52% qui ne fait
pas la même chose avec les salariés
l'anticipation la préparation la gestion
de crise voilà ce que ne s'est pas fait
le gouvernement se glisse dans les
négociations entre la direction totale
et salariés en tout cas il aurait dû
suivre ça de plus près et ne pas se
retrouver le bec dans l'eau le bec de
négociations salariales
plus rien nous allons de crise en crise
avec un état qui est là les bras
ballants et qui explique aux Français ah
bah la crise et là il va falloir vous
serrer la ceinture il va falloir arrêter
de rouler en fait on a un gouvernement
qui gère la galère des Français la
galère dans les transports les galères
dans les soins la galère dans la
consommation la galère dans l'inflation
les Français sont en galère dans tous
les domaines et on a un gouvernement qui
les regarde et qui dit oh bah mes
pauvres amis il va falloir que ça soit
vous qui fassiez les efforts il y en a
marre il faut un gouvernement qui agisse
à une atteinte au droit de grève
je crois que la réquisition est un
phénomène qui existe il va falloir
qu'elle se fasse dans les règles il va
falloir qu'elle se fasse le plus
courtoisement j'allais dire possible
mais notre pays ne peut pas vivre sans
carburant c'est une évidence
est annoncé hier est-ce que vous
demandez aussi des réquisitions chez
Total total qui a annoncé ce matin que
la grève était conduite dans tous les
sites impliqués et qu'il faut le faire
pour assurer la vie normale des Français
il faudra le faire et une fois encore je
suis pas aux affaires mais s'il faut le
faire dès aujourd'hui il faut le faire
dès aujourd'hui une fois encore la
France ne peut pas être bloquée mais je
le répète nous vivons comme nous avons
vécu dans tous les domaines le manque
d'anticipation de ce gouvernement
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à la CGT qui
dit on nous interdit du coup de
revendiquer et d'exprimer une
revendications non mais revendiquer
c'est pas bloqué il y a d'autres moyens
de faire valoir ces demandes légitimes
ou pas c'est pas à moi d'en juger que
par le fait de bloquer un pays et il y a
derrière des enjeux de santé il y a des
enjeux de sécurité il y a des enjeux
économiques notre pays va très mal donc
chaque atteinte à l'activité économique
chaque atteinte à la sécurité
supplémentaire mais notre pays en grave
danger un dernier mot là-dessus puisque
vous parlez d'attaque sur les super
profils le Gouvernement présente un
amendement budget qui crée une
contribution de solidarité
exceptionnelle justement sur les
bénéfices de ces entreprises c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour vous finalement
c'est une forme de taxe sur les super
confiée oui et non parce que vu comment
c'est rédigé on n'est pas bien sûr de ce
que cela donne moi je si le gouvernement
est sincère je ne comprends toujours pas
pourquoi il n'a pas voté notre
amendement et notre projet que nous
l'avons présenté probablement pour des
raisons
politiciennes
des mesures que nous proposons qui a par
exemple on parle du carburant on voit
bien que les Français aujourd'hui ont du
mal à faire leur plein ça continue on
revoit des prix du litre à 2 euros
revenir je vous rappelle qu'à la fin du
mois les ristournes vont diminuer que
les Français vont se retrouver à nouveau
devant une essence très chère nous on a
une solution simple facile à TVA de 20%
à 5 et demi pour cent sur les produits
énergétiques le gouvernement s'obstine à
ne pas faire alors d'autres pays
d'Europe l'ont fait alors ils nous ment
il nous dit qu'on ne peut pas parce
qu'on est en Union Européenne il nous
dit parce que ce n'est pas raisonnable
c'est faux d'autres pays le font et ça
fonctionne pourquoi est-ce qu'il refuse
mais je crois que c'est parce que ça
vient de nous on va parler de ce qui
s'est passé hier à l'Assemblée question
d'actualité un peu où le on va regarder
cet échange entre le député du
rassemblement national Alexandre Loubet
et le ministre
vous avez travaillé il fut un temps pour
Dominique de Villepin qui avait dénoncé
la lâcheté de ceux qui refusent de
défendre les intérêts de la France
aujourd'hui le lâche c'est vous
de réputé Loubet
j'ai l'honneur de demander des excuses
solennelles au rassemblement national
pour avoir employé le terme de lâche à
une personne qui a toujours fait preuve
de courage dans son engagement politique
depuis 20 ans qu'il fait de la politique
au service de la France et des Français
alors au mois de juillet vous avez
revendiqué le fait d'être une opposition
calme respectueuse des règles est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on regarde cette
scène on assiste on se dit on assiste un
changement de ton est-ce qu'il va durer
pas du tout le moulage est un adjectif
qualificatif ce n'est pas une insulte
c'est un trait de caractère négatif on
est d'accord mais c'est un trait de
caractère et il se trouve que ce trait
de caractère est celui de Monsieur le
Maire dire la vérité à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pas insulter en revanche
empêcher un député de dire la vérité ça
commence à devenir un petit peu
dangereux de merde un autre député a dit
que monsieur papendaye était
communautariste il est communautariste
c'est pas une insulte pour Monsieur
papenne Guy c'est un trade caractère si
on ne peut plus parler librement à
l'Assemblée nationale alors c'est un
recul terrible de la démocratie remettre
en question l'attitude le comportement
d'un ministre sans insulter je le répète
là je n'ai pas une insulte alors si on
ne peut plus faire ça et bien c'est un
recul terrible on voit bien que le
gouvernement personnel on voit bien
qu'il s'impatiente quand même
elle elle insulte par son attitude
physique elle a insulte par les mots
qu'elle prononce le mot lâche je le
répète n'est pas une insulte à l'âge
c'est quoi c'est quelqu'un qui recule
devant l'obstacle quel meilleur
définition que cela de Monsieur Bruno Le
Maire qui est incapable de ramener la
souveraineté industrielle en France qui
laisse partir des pépites de l'industrie
notamment de l'industrie de défense ce
qui est très grave dans les mains des
Américains ou de puissance étrangères
oui c'est de la lâcheté alors en tout
cas vous ne présenterez pas d'excuses
puisque Bruno Le Maire vous demande des
excuses est-ce que vous allez la France
on dit la vérité donc non a provoqué un
certain Brouard dans l'hémicycle votre
groupe a décidé de quitter l'hémicycle
hier après-midi les Français depuis le
mois de juillet regardent ce désordre au
sein de l'Assemblée nationale d'un œil
un peu perplexe voire parfois critique
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne image à donner de la politique moi
je crois qu'il y a une
instrumentalisation un
instrumentalisation de la caisse de
résonance qu'elle a sur les nationales
notamment par la nupesse qui se comporte
n'importe comment qui a fait de ce cœur
de notre démocratie un cirque ambulant
et il y a son utilisation par le
gouvernement qui joue les vierges les
farouchers à la moindre parole pour
faire croire il serait insulté non non
le mot en soi le ministre n'aurait pas
dû réagir comme ça madame la présidente
de l'Assemblée n'aurait pas dû rappeler
à l'ordre Alexandre le web moi je
rappelle que dans ce même cycle nous
avons été traités de nazi de fasciste de
pétainiste que même à député de la
majorité attendu le bras en l'air
lorsque nous nous sommes exprimés j'ai
l'impression que il y avait moins de
révoltes alors que là c'était vraiment
des insultes hier la député de la
majorité pour le coup Astrid panoson a
appris aussi elle aussi un rappel à
l'ordre un rappel de la part de Yaël
brunchviller parce qu'elle s'est
adressée à vos députés en disant
difficile de masquer un ADN xénophobe du
haut de 50 ans ça veut dire que là la
sanction dial brun Pivet elle est
justifiée
c'est un caractère politique
Mathilde panot et l'illustration du mot
outrance donc on va pas s'attarder sur
son cas mais ce que je crois c'est une
insulte mais là c'est un ministre c'est
pas une insulte
dictionnaire vous verrez en face du
moulage qu'il n'y a pas marqué insultes
xénophobe clairement ça fait référence
notamment à des choses qui sont
interdites etc donc oui c'est une
insulte mais une fois encore ne
sanctionne pas que les députés du
rassemblement national elle a aussi
sanctionné une députée de sa majorité
oui d'accord mais pas pour des faits de
la même gravité mais honnêtement est-ce
que vous croyez que ce matin c'est le
sujet que nous devons évoquer à propos
de l'Assemblée nationale il y a
aujourd'hui un budget qui est proposé au
vote un budget qui ne répond en rien au
défi de notre pays au défi de l'école au
défi de la sécurité au défi de
l'industrialisation au défi du chômage
et les filles de la dette tout cela
n'est pas répondu alors le gouvernement
qu'est-ce qu'il fait comme à son
habitude il détourne l'attention c'est
exactement la manipulation qui a fait
hier Monsieur le Maire mais c'est parce
que vous avez fait j'insiste c'est parce
que vous avez fait en essayant de
quitter l'hémicycle vous envoyez une
image aux Français qui est forte de qui
était l'hémicycle c'est pas c'est pas
anodin nous disons aux Français nous
sommes une opposition déterminée nous
continuerons à dire la vérité coûte que
coûte nous sommes en démocratie nous
sommes probablement les défenseurs les
plus ardents de cette démocratie dans
l'hémicycle nous ne nous laisserons pas
faire nous ne laisseront pas les 13
millions d'électeurs de Marine Le Pen se
faire maltraiter à l'Assemblée nationale
jamais on va parler du budget du 49-3 le
gouvernement dit lui-même que ce 49-3
Paris incontournable est-ce que vous
l'espérez rapide ou est-ce que vous
espérez avoir des débats qui s'étale
quand même un peu dans l'hémicycle mais
évidemment que le principe même de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le débat que
nous regardions chaque point que nous en
discutions nous nous avons des points à
amener au débat la priorité nationale la
baisse de la TVA on en a parlé la
réindustrialisation les forces scolaires
qui est à faire l'effort sur la sécurité
l'aide à nos communes quand lequel
aimeriez-vous voir inscrire dans ce
budget il y en a beaucoup je pense que
la priorité nationale
recouvre beaucoup de sujets elle
recouvre le logement elle recouvre
l'emploi elle recouvre l'impôt elle
recouvre beaucoup de choses et c'est au
coeur de notre programme le 49-3 c'est
une solution de facilité si vous me le
permettez c'est une solution un peu
lâche
décidément
vous allez déposer une motion de censure
votre groupe va déposer une notion de
censure elle a peu de chances de passer
puisque le groupe les républicains
visiblement ne la votera pas à quoi ça
sert
qui sort le 49.3 retrouve une motion de
censure en face de lui c'est le jeu et
on le sait le gouvernement ne sera pas
surpris je suis très heureux que nous
présentions cette motion de censure et
nous la voterons nous évidemment les
républicains seront au pied du mur
est-ce que c'est une force d'opposition
ou est-ce qu'ils sont simplement les
supplétifs d'un gouvernement en mal de
vote est-ce que pour défendre leur siège
coûte que coûte ils sont prêts à toutes
les compromissions et ce qu'ils
acceptent que la France
en fait au final s'il s'oppose alors
qu'il voit que la leçon de censure mais
non parce que si on veut un budget sur
le négocier et bien ça veut dire qu'on
ne parle pas des 600 milliards de dettes
qui vont être aggravés de 150 milliards
supplémentaires on ne parle pas des 5,4
millions de chômeurs qui font que nous
sommes en chômage endémique on ne parle
pas de la baisse de productivité des
entreprises françaises on ne parle pas
de l'écroulement du niveau scolaire on
ne parle pas de l'immigration et de la
sécurité s'ils acceptent pour ne parlent
pas de tout ça à quoi servent-ils
pourquoi pas
mais bien sûr une fois encore nous
avions toujours le même principe nouveau
ton en fonction de l'intérêt des
Français quel que soit l'origine de
l'amendement du projet ou de la
proposition de loi ou même de la motion
de censure donc est-ce qu'il va vous
décider oui ça sera oui le vote de la
notion de la nuque mais nous verrons
bien à laquelle notion de censure est
proposée à l'Assemblée nationale d'où
elles viennent nous la voterons 7000 les
oppositions détricoter la loi de
programmation budgétaire Gabriel Attal
le ministre des comptes publics parle de
coalition de l'irresponsabilités
on laisse monsieur Attal parler comme ça
aux députés de la nation vous voyez ce
deux points de mesure est quand même
très inquiétant donc au contraire c'est
très responsable par exemple cette nuit
grâce notamment à l'action des députés
du rassemblement national nous avons
tordu le coup à un projet du
gouvernement qui était une crise
d'austérité pour les communes notamment
sur le budget des communes on leur
demande de plus en plus on réduit leurs
ressources fiscales et en même temps si
je puis dire on leur demande de faire
des efforts budgétaires alors d'ailleurs
que le budget de l'État serait en
déficit faites ce que je dis mais non
pas ce que je fais et bien nous avons
permis de casser ce projet nous en
sommes très fiers c'est ça une
opposition constructive c'est ça une
opposition de terrain c'est ça ou une
opposition à l'écoute un mot sur le la
ce qui concerne la défense notamment
l'autre programmation militaire puisque
c'est un sujet que vous suivez à
l'Assemblée elle doit être présentée
avant la fin de l'année pour la période
2024 2030 il y a des inquiétudes parmi
les parlementaires surtout dans le
contexte actuel évidemment vous faites
partie de ceux qui s'inquiètent oui
c'est extrêmement inquiétant alors il
faut noter effectivement que le budget
serait en augmentation de 3 milliards
pour passer à 44 milliards annuels mais
ces 3 milliards correspondent à peine
finalement à l'augmentation due à
l'inflation il y a un retard qui a été
accumulé pendant des années nous nous
avons évalué à 55 milliards le besoin
c'est à dire 11 milliards
supplémentaires c'est d'ailleurs ce que
proposait Marine Le Pen ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il y aura
finalement des pénuries d'armement ça
veut dire que si nous sommes
[Musique]
vous n'êtes plus un interlocuteur
crédible soyons très clair il y a un
agresseur et un agressé c'est clairement
la Russie qui a agressé c'est clairement
Vladimir Poutine qui a une attitude
guerrière inacceptable aujourd'hui et
c'est clairement l'Ukraine dont il faut
retrouver les frontières et la
souveraineté mais le dialogue est une
notion qui a été perdue d'autres pays je
vous seront aujourd'hui la Chine la
turquiemment la musique j'ai dialogué
avec Vladimir Poutine au début et puis
finalement le dialogue s'avère
impossible donc il a raté c'est un aveu
d'échec est-ce qu'il faut pour autant se
livrer à la course à l'armement est-ce
qu'il faut pour le temps pour autant se
livrer à la course à la fin de la
des armes en Ukraine en tout cas il faut
faire très attention il faut faire très
attention pour deux raisons d'abord de
pas devenir Colombie gérant et ne pas
dépouiller la limite et ne pas
dépouiller à nos armées parce que je
rappelle que ces armes ne sont pas des
armes qui sont construites pour
l'occasion ce sont des armes qui
viennent de nos propres équipements qui
sont déjà insuffisants aujourd'hui de
renforcer les effectifs en Roumanie par
exemple qui je conçois vigilant en
Roumanie non c'est pas forcément quelque
chose de critiquable là où il adore le
président de la République
j'ai pas tous les éléments mais a priori
c'est une hypothèse qui n'est pas
forcément farfelue en revanche en
revanche je trouve que l'effort
diplomatique qui a toujours incombé à la
France dans son histoire je me rappelle
de la politique gaullienne en matière
d'affaires étrangère n'a pas été menée à
son terme n'a pas été mené tambour
battant et malheureusement d'autres pays
j'allais dire un peu moins dignes de
confiance comme la Turquie ont pris ce
rôle vous trouvez que les formes
militaire lui a été trop important je
trouve que avant de livrer des camions
César à l'Ukraine en dépouillant nos
armées il aurait fallu en France le pays
d'Europe qui consacre le moins d'argent
à l'aide à l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
quasiment c'est normal non vous parlez
d'argent moi je vous parle d'armement
c'est pas forcément exactement la même
chose clairement il faut aider l'Ukraine
je pense qu'il faut l'aider notamment en
accueillant des réfugiés il faut
maintenir des sanctions contre la Russie
pas sur les biens énergétiques parce que
ça c'est les Français qui en payent le
prix mais sur les biens de haute
technologie sur les avoir des oligarques
il faut bien évidemment mener des
actions ne me faites pas dire ce que
j'ai pas dit en revanche lorsque ces
actions sont nuisibles à l'intérêt de la
France et à l'intérêt de la paix il ne
faut pas les mener et là il faut
réaccueillir des réfugiés la situation
s'aggrave aujourd'hui en Ukraine il faut
le faire vous voyez la question que pose
cet accueil des réfugiés Ukrainiens
c'est quand il y a des vrais réfugiés il
y a des gens qui fuient vraiment la
guerre aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus les
structures d'accueil pourquoi parce
qu'elles sont remplies de gens qui sont
de faux réfugiés et donc ça remet en
cause même notre politique de droit
d'asile et d'analyse des des réfugiés
que nous devons accueillir en ne
sélectionnant pas finalement en ne
faisant pas le tri entre les faux
réfugiés les vrais réfugiés nous mettons
les vrais réfugiés en danger on va
parler de la réforme de la police
judiciaire un réforme controversée
présentée par par Gérald Darmanin
contester par les policiers contestés
aussi par les procureurs est-ce que
géraldar maintenant doit la maintenir
est-ce que vous soutenez vous cette
réforme non je ne crois pas je crois
qu'il y a à voir aujourd'hui l'attitude
des policiers qui envoient un signal
très clair à Monsieur Darmanin très fort
quand on voit des policiers tourner le
dos à des officiels dans certains
commissariats comme on l'a vu c'est que
la situation est grave parce que ce sont
en général des gens qui ont un droit de
réserve et qui l'appliquent strictement
monsieur Darmanin est hors-sol comme
tous les ministres de ce gouvernement il
prend des décisions dans son coin avec
seulement deux objectifs
sauver sa peau et faire de la com voilà
l'intérêt général semble absent de leur
préoccupations la concertation semble
absente de leur méthode clairement ça ne
passe pas alors clairement il faut
revoir la copie ce deuxième semestre
2023 ça laisse le temps de la
concertation pour le coup bah oui mais
enfin apparemment les annonces ont été
faites avant les concertations mais
surtout le monsieur Darmanin devra je
crois un moment faire son propre bilan
explosion de l'immigration légale et
illégale explosion des grâces des
agressions à sécurité permanente et
partout dans le moindre village on l'a
vu avec la crise d'élérodéo on le voit
avec les cambriolages qui ont lieu
monsieur Darmanin n'est pas compétent
n'est pas efficace alors et je pense que
l'assemblée qui prévoit justement plus
de moyens pour les forces de l'ordre
est-ce que vous allez la voter cette loi
mais s'il y a plus de moyens pour les
forces de l'ordre nous verrons le texte
mais c'est probable que nous le votions
mais ce n'est pas que d'une question de
moyens c'est une question de soutien
aussi quand on a un président de la
République qui laisse dire qu'il y
aurait racisme endémique et systémique
dans la police clairement c'est pas un
soutien moral il soutient pas assez les
forces de l'ordre pour vous parce que
beaucoup lui reprochent le contraire
d'autres soutenir les forces de l'ordre
et c'est déjà beaucoup par rapport au
ministre précédent mais dans l'action il
se passe quoi mais le problème je vais
vous dire c'est à la fois Monsieur
Darmanin mais c'est aussi et surtout
monsieur Dupond-Moretti qui est le
ministre des prisonniers plutôt que le
ministre des victimes qui est le
ministre des racailles plutôt que le
ministre des policiers et donc quand la
justice et laxiste vous pouvez mettre
100000 policiers derrière chaque voyou
si ce voyou au final n'est pas jugé et
ne va pas en prison tout cela ne sert à
rien
devant la Cour de justice
qui renvoyait dans la cour de justice de
la République pour sa gestion du covid
les magistrats envisagent une mise en
examen de l'ancien Premier ministre
est-ce que de votre point de vue c'est
une décision qui est justifiée écoutez
nous verrons bien ce qui lui est
clairement reproché il est en tout cas
justifié de faire le bilan de cette
politique est-ce que ce dosha doit se
faire sur la justice je n'en suis pas
tout à fait sûr mais je respecte les
décisions de justice clairement on a là
un homme un chef de gouvernement qui
lorsque il a eu les premières alertes
venues de Chine n'a pris aucune décision
d'urgence lorsqu'il a fallu protéger les
Français nous a déclaré que le masque ne
servait à rien pour cacher d'ailleurs le
fait que les stocks avaient été détruits
on a un Premier ministre qui a couvert
un gouvernement qui a menti et qui a
failli et bien dans une république ça ne
peut pas rester sans analyse du bilan
écoutez qu'ils doivent s'exprimer et
qu'ils doivent se justifier paraît
logique est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à
une accusation en examen nous verrons
bien de quelle manière ça pourrait être
examiné puisque vous souhaitez que ce
soit je pense que là le Parlement a
beaucoup pas faire dans des commissions
bancaires etc et que c'est aussi souvent
lorsque c'est sans effet que les mesures
qui ont amené à prendre ces décisions
inhiques ne sont pas corrigées on voit
bien d'ailleurs crise après crise ce
gouvernement n'attirait aucune leçon des
crises passées toujours un préparer
toujours dans la course à la mesure de
restriction toujours à faire payer aux
Français en réduisant leur liberté le
manque de préparation
à l'Assemblée où je comprends mal je
vous dis que ce serait le rôle de
l'Assemblée le problème c'est que
lorsque l'assemblée fait des commissions
d'enquête derrière malheureusement il ne
se passe rien une dernière oui le 5
novembre prochain le rassemblement
national aura un nouveau président de
candidats sont en lice lui a lieu Jordan
Marlena vous se
Jordan Bardella parce que avec Jordan je
crois notre partie a montré qu'il était
capable de devenir un parti de
gouvernement Jordan avec Marine Le Pen
on fait un duo exceptionnel dans toutes
les dernières élections l'élection
présidentielle ou le parti à largement
soutenu la candidate et nous avons
traversé des crises avec l'arrivée
d'Éric Zemmour par exemple nous les
avons traversé sans dommage
Marine Le Pen est présidente du groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale et la figure
tutélaire de notre mouvement à titre
personnel je souhaite qu'elle soit notre
candidate en 2027 parce que on est tout
à fait capable qu'elle a ce lien
particulier avec les Français Jordan
Bardella a fait un super beau
aujourd'hui ça c'est elle est la seule à
pouvoir vous répondre Jordan a fait un
super boulot on ne change pas une équipe
qui gagne j'espère qu'il sera notre
président merci Laurent merci à vous
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
la Une de La Dépêche c'est évidemment la
crise des carburants la France à sec ça
suffit c'est à la Une de votre journal
Christelle merci Christelle à mercredi
et merci beaucoup Laurent jacobelli on
passe au club des territoires
[Musique]